le croquemitaine tout ce temps passé à
te cacher à te préparer tout ça pour
rien thomas fait en priorité avant ta
famille d'ailleurs ça t'a coûté famille
c'est la façon dont j'ai de l'état mr a
fait qu'elle me détestent mais que les
préparer à affronter les horreurs de ce
mandat alors alors ça me va dit adieu à
michael et tourner la page
[Musique]
réf
karen
michael est ici descend tout de suite tu
es moche toi dépêche toi
[Musique]
y'a plein de maisons aussi mais elles
sont toutes plus bottes
j'irais bien mort c'est là le bas de
votre côté d'or
messier
il y à 40 ans la nuit d'halloween
michael myers a assassiné trois
personnes la presse est horrible nuit il
a retourné en hôpital psychiatrique et
il en est plus sorti
[Musique]
depuis cette nuit là sucrier tous les
soirs pour qu'ils s'évadent pourquoi
faire une chose paraît
pour lui faire la peau
[Musique]
depuis ça a eu un accident michael myers
s'étaient jetés
il va retourner à deauville c'est chez
lui je dois protéger ma famille
t'as pas de système de sécurité karen
faut que tu te fasses itema mots mal
existe c'est pas pour rien si on est
censé avoir peur 7 milliards
[Musique]
ça fait longtemps que je me prépare pour
cette nuit il ne faut surtout pas
traîner dans les rues ce soir c'est un
tueur mais séduit qui sera tuée cette
nuit
joyeux halloween maintenant
[Musique]